the average man overestimates his
fighting ability by one thousand percent
the average poker player overestimates
their ability by one million percent but
what if there was a way to prove it to
go all the way to winning the World
Series of Poker without spending a
single penny I'm excited to announce
that I am now working with GG porker the
best poker site in the world and I'm
gonna be bringing you the best
tournaments that you can be involved
with as a fan of me and poker starting
this Thursday and every Thursday after
that we are playing free roles with all
of you online on JJ poker and I need all
of of you like to get involved this
Thursday the top 20 percent will be
getting a share of 1 000 tournament
dollars and for everyone who makes the
final table you will get a ticket to
continue in the micro Festival series
which has a guaranteed prize pool of 10
million dollars oh and that's a cheeky
little bonus if you're not Mio which
even Conor McGregor couldn't do you'll
get a hundred dollars in your account in
cash so the whole thing kicks off this
Thursday at 6 p.m live on Twitch I'll be
streaming the whole thing so if you're
kicking my ass it will be there for
everyone to see and the reason why you
need to be involved from the store is
that three of you lot over the course of
this series will be chosen to play with
me at the World Series of Poker in
London you lucky Lucky Bastards so don't
forget click the link in the description
below and you can find my game search
true Geordie and the password will be
true Geordie all one word I can't wait
to see you there and find out who gonna
win a share of one thousand dollars be
gamble aware Gumball responsibly guys
thanks for everything thanks to GG poker
and I'll let you guys now enjoy the
video
[Music]
you know how they play
[Applause]
we got a phone call after my consolation
and you give me some amazing words was
it helpful oh you are beautiful mate and
because you've been through it all
before a million times it feels on a
weekly basis sometimes
and just to have someone who's been
there seeing it got the T-shirt give me
that encouragement and say you're a
builder you've built something you can't
take that away no matter how what people
say
and this is temporary and yeah yeah it
really helped me mate thank you oh
cheers Brian thank you very much we
I suppose that it's very exciting to
live in other people's impressions of
you when other people's impressions of
you are positive but I said that
sometimes that collateral is gonna get
cashed in and because I've been famous
for a while I've experienced various the
vicissitudes of it the fluctuations how
do you handle that because I find it
like because I've got depression and on
a clinical level and I've been on
medication for it so I've always found
those laws hard anyway but the
Ridiculousness of uh when all of those
waves of hatred come through it is a bit
like you're kind of in a storm and you
feel like you're just having to like
rains it in your face and you're like I
just got to breathe this for a minute
here some of the teachers that I really
highly regard and respect would say that
the reason we feel uh sad or afraid or
ashamed aimed when something external
happens is because those feelings were
in us anyway like when and the the
outside stimulant or apparently external
Factor simply provokes something that
was within us one time I did this thing
with gab or may uh you know the uh he's
an addiction expert Holocaust Survivor
Hungarian Man Truth teller brilliant
compassionate soul I love him and
respect him so much he wrote the book in
the realm of the Hungry Ghost he's uh I
don't want doing his promo his uh
current book he's got a comedy if you
are coming soon
the myth of normal which is sort of like
a recent book he did anyway we did this
talk in front of people you know and I
interviewed him and at the end we spoke
to this like we did like questions and
this woman said oh there's this young
person in my life who's suffering from
addiction how do I help him and he goes
well firstly who is the person what's
your relationship to him is it you're
like a child of yours or are you their
therapist and she goes it's my son he
goes well obviously that's different and
when you think about the inner your
inability to help this person where do
you feel in your body sort of says my
chest she indicated her chest and he
said have you ever felt those feelings
before and she went yeah
and he goes I don't think that this
feeling is about this person I think
that you have this feeling in you and
you have to address this feeling in
yourself you have to learn to let go of
it you have to
accept this feeling in yourself and let
go of it and recognize these persons on
their own Journey how can the the speed
with which Gabon mate made this
diagnosis was really sort of interesting
and I would say shamanic and the reason
I say shamanic is Shamanism is regarded
as the first religion prior to the
institutional religion should we call
them Catholicism and of the various
priorities of Christianity and the
various branches of Islam and Buddhism
there were tribal religions usually
based on the relationship that the
people had either with the the animals
that they hunted or the crops that they
grew that they needed to have a because
if you're looking for food all the time
your survival is based on your ability
to access this food so you need to tune
into the behavior of the animal you need
to tune into the weather you need to Pro
you pray that the crop is not going to
fail you pray that you will find the
animal so like that your relationship
with the sacred is highly pragmatic now
that we live you know yard from a
budgens or a walk-in walkout Amazon food
place or a Whole Foods or a little
depending on your economic barrier and
Asda where if you dare glance at the
ceiling in as they you'll see that
you're in advance a vast unknowable
Hangar don't look up in ASDA you'll see
that no inside space should be that
massive the the use instead of thinking
about survival you think about you know
your status everything becomes sort of
tangential so what Gabon mati did in
that moment is he was able to say where
in your body is this feeling and how are
we going to help one another if we sort
of can't help ourselves so when there is
a sort of like a moment of crisis in my
own life and they come pretty frequently
what I recognize is I'm holding on to
all the pain from when I was a little
kid I'm in fact I'm trying to solve the
problems of my trauma or my feelings of
I don't know inferiority or fear or
whatever you want to call it by managing
the outside world trying to make it so
that nothing challenges me so that
nothing makes me feel frightened and
inferior but for a person like me all I
need to do is participate in a fighter
side football match to be exposed to to
the limitations of what I'm capable of
controlling and to see that oh my God
I'm not good at this I can't cope in a
transition I don't know how to Mark I
don't know when to shoot I don't know
when to lay off you know so um when
these things happen sooner or later you
have to make peace with yourself you
have to look for these opportunities to
let go of fear when it comes up or shame
and to recognize we know where this ends
you know what's the best case scenario
on a deathbed surrounded by your loved
ones like or is it a sudden adventurous
death on a mountain top or scuba diving
I don't know you tell me you know and
sooner or later it's coming so I guess
we have to make peace with not live in
the bubble of reputation I think as it
Shakespeare call it that was it radio
Kipling don't live in the bubble of
reputation you mentioned that you're you
regularly experience crisis
um and will you come across as just the
person who has everything that together
like when I watch you I think this man
just has you seem to have life licked
okay when was the last time you cried or
got angry or both like last time I would
like sort of cried in a full body type
crying yeah was when my cat Morrissey
died at a sort of not long after my
friend Martino died and I felt like sort
of the both of those you know that
person and that cat I'd known uh like
from I guess early recovery or even with
Martino me and him were friends while I
was still using and I felt like in a way
that you know like people like witches
have a familiar you know like you had
like the black cat and the witch image
is like that that's the familiar and I
wonder what the the idea of having a
familiar is is it to Anchor you to the
body if you're a Mystic if you're a
person that deals with uh if you deal
with layers of reality the one of the
qualities of the shaman is the shaman
switches levels we have to be able to
live in the world but not be of it in
the words of Jesus Christ you have to
accept you've got a body
you've got to pay the rent you've got to
be fit you've got to eat well you have
to abide by the customers Traditions
regulations and and laws of the society
that you find yourself in but if you
define yourself solely by that in the
end it's not going to be enough in the
end your heart will be broken in the end
people will die that you love when my
cat Morrissey died it was felt like that
this little cat had been there sort of
the he had held for me a lot I got him
when I was one year clean when I lived
right round here where we're recording
this in North London
and by the time that cat died I had
children and I'm married and I live in
the countryside and I've been flung
around the cess pit and uh the cesspit
and the ball pit of Fame
and feel like I have a different and
more remote relationship with it and
when he died a lot that a lot of my a
lot of things I carried went with him
and I properly grieved him I'm afraid I
have the Good Fortune of a friendship
with that mad scientist Professor Noel
Fitzpatrick aka the super vet
and like I said I think this cat you
know he's dying now he said like he'd
come round and like help you know to
deal with it I was really grateful that
the cat died that he died in his own
time in the end you see that he was
being artificially artificially
suspended he couldn't poo on his own he
couldn't eat on his own I was sustaining
him only for myself because of my own
inability to let go of him I went from
praying for him to continue living to
praying for him to die peacefully that I
suppose is a good that's a sign that
you're ready to let go of something or
someone and when he like died I thought
the grief ripped through me the same
with my mate Martino it was a person
that had been friends with various
expressions of myself both Martino and
the cat Morrissey had known me like in
bed sits and in mansions in Los Angeles
and London different
inflections of Life what it is when you
don't have access to resources and you
don't have status to what it is when you
do have access to resources and you do
have status and then when those things
become disenchanting at this point in my
life may I suppose what I'm feeling is
is a pla I've arrived at a point of
wanting to be able to let go of
accepting that you can achieve more when
you let go of your will than you can
when you're trying to weaponize your
will when you're trying to direct the
will do you mean like almost bully
things into existence rather than
allowing it yeah I think I do mean that
using your will to become successful
like I can't do this I can because
it's interesting isn't it you can direct
your personal power to build a business
you can do that you can make yourself
fit you can do all sorts of stuff and in
a way I'm not talking about the
objective I'm talking about the mindset
of it that when I Surrender and this is
something that's very recent and only
really bought about by a sort of
successive
events for the feeling that oh God I
can't really control I can't control the
world in the way that I once thought
that I could now
I'm I feel more like I'm being carried
and held by something else there still
is a sort of a sadness that comes with
it there's a sadness in letting go
there's a sadness in knowing that you've
believed in things and that they're not
real the sort of relationships that are
expunged and that disappear all of these
things that there is a sort of a sadness
in them but when my life is just about
the Fulfillment of what I want it's such
a short little Carousel it's such a
short little cycle and now I feel like
oh I'm actually in a position where I
can stop doing stuff in order that I
might achieve something else down the
line and I can just start doing what I
actually believe in really really
directly and what I believe in now is
personal Awakening and participating
where possible in The Awakening of
others and that does involve critiquing
political and economic systems and
critiquing the media and Analysis I
guess that's interesting are they
telling you and they're not telling you
that and why are they emphasizing that
and why didn't they admit that then like
you know there are interesting lines of
inquiry to go down but beyond that it's
deeper than that because civilization is
just like a veil laying upon the Earth
so temporal and temporary all gone now
where are they you know like uh
Shelley's famous poeing
Ozymandias King of Kings look ye upon my
works and despair it stands this statue
in the desert nothing around it for
miles and miles everything that's
achieved where will it all be even me
revisiting Camden all of the bars and
pubs and scenes of Triumph and disaster
all different now new buildings erected
new businesses erected new voices if
those are the things I'm going to form
my life around
you know what value is it really you
don't give yourself enough credit oh
thanks because
you are one of the few people out there
who is clearly
having a big audience and using it for
the greater good
and for all you may feel like oh it's
not going the way I hoped it would when
I was a younger more uh maybe ego Driven
Man and believed a bit too much in what
you were able to do what you've been
able to do was still amazing and the the
difference that you are making for
people like me who is I'm not as
intelligent as you and I don't have the
resources that you do but you're able to
break and condense things down so that
we as your fans can get that message in
a much more bite-sized understandable
way and even if you kind of feel like I
don't know maybe that young man where
you're talking in sort of a uh
uh sort of remembering who you once were
is if you're having to let that person
go you're making that person very proud
still surely in a sense I'm letting go
of that person because the alternative
is to hold on to it and there's nothing
more
terrible and Dreadful than the oldest
swinger in town in the convertible and
uh dyed blonde hair in the sort of the
ongoing wanting so there's sort of like
in a sense there's no choice but to let
go and I suppose I want to be where I'm
you know Joseph Campbell says like if
you're 40 years old and you're still
frightened of your mother you need to
read myth if you're 80 years old and you
still care about your golf score you
need to read myth these are the two
examples that you gave and I suppose
what he's saying is that there are
stories derived from archetypes that
help to inform us of the gateways that
we will pass through in life that are
adolescence when we leave childhood
behind we're going to be confronted with
certain choices
when we recognize that we are
responsible for other people's
well-being there will be certain choices
that we make when we Face the
disappointment of knowing that we can't
expect other people to carry out gold
for us that other people will let us
down that love necessarily mutates into
something more grounded that there's
pain that comes with all these things
now like letting go of the person that I
was when I was 25 or 30 or 16 or
whatever it's sort of like a a necessary
grieving and it's also the beauty in is
it in it is that I get to become someone
else and the person I was when I was 25
or 30 couldn't be a father to two
daughters and couldn't deal with the
challenges that I face now so there is a
sort of a sadness but there's kind of
not Pride because Pride as I understand
it now means caring about what other
people think of me and of course I do
but I recognize it's something that I
want to let go of and where possible
I or Brian replace Pride with gratitude
because in a sense any ability that you
or I are born with most of them they're
just there is kind of a genetic
aristocracy to be born with willpower or
Talent or something that's conveniently
monetizable in the culture that you
happen to find yourself in Imagine
LeBron James in
medieval Pakistan if you can conceive of
such a thing is there such a thing as
medieval Pakistan I don't know that you
couldn't even apply that
categorization but that skill set is
only valuable yeah in 21st and 20th late
20th century America like that and my
school said in your skill set we're just
sort of lucky that we've landed
ourselves in the place that we have in
the time that we have and
so also though to your point and I said
it to you last time I was on you have
cultivated for yourself an important
voice and an important following and I
feel that this space that we work in and
we must always pay homage to the great
Avatar an alpha figure that is Joe Rogan
is an opportunity for men to talk about
mental health and wellness and fitness
and hopefully to be participate in a
conversation about how maleness
masculinity
as well as a a scope scale and spectrum
of other forms of identity might evolve
how we might talk about
mental and physical fitness in ways that
like it just didn't seem to be possible
30 years ago when these kind of spaces
weren't available and although like part
of it is MMA and Sport and hunting and
carnivore diets and things that seem
overtly traditionally and typically male
it does also include psychedelics and
meditation and breath work and
open-mindedness about the Academia and a
discussion and discourse around
Progressive issues and how they might
align and marry with traditionalism and
I think you're doing a really really
great job in that space and making
mistakes like all of us must because the
only way to not make mistakes is to
accept other people's ideas and not to
be involved in the conversation at all
yeah and unfortunately our mistakes play
out in front of more people than other
people's mistakes do you know and I
think all you can do is hold your hands
up when these things happen and in terms
of masculinity
um there's a lot of people who feel like
there's an attack on masculinity right
now and you're a really interesting
person in terms of where you fit on this
the spectrum of masculinity because on
the one hand you've always well when
especially when you were younger you're
very flamboyant and had a sort of
um I don't know if feminine is the right
word but you know that like androgynous
yeah yeah you were very uh you were very
flamboyant with your humor however you
have a lot of masculine qualities which
is very confident very strong spoken and
very intelligent and you're a performer
um so yeah do you think that there's an
attack on masculinity and how do you
feel about your own masculinity I feel
like there's an interesting cultural
conversation taking place around power
and how power
is expressed through different
individuals and different cultural
groups for example you may frequently
hear conversations around the how women
are represented in powerful roles in
business or in politics and some people
would regard that as an important
conversation and and perhaps it is one
another important conversation might be
that if these institutions are an
expression of traditional and
patriarchal power
simply putting women into those roles
may not be the best way to evolve and
create a better and more representative
Society I.E if Parliament is primarily a
patriarchal system once it was only
possible for men to vote once it was
only possible for men to have to be MPS
then by permitting women to vote and
permitting women to be in Parliament are
you solving the problem or are you
merely all wearing some of the
superficial aspects of course not saying
that we just Vote or that women
shouldn't be able to be MPS I'm actually
saying we should be looking beyond that
to different types of Institutions that
are truly representative so even when
there's a conversation about
progressivism and uh women participating
in places where they previously wouldn't
and all of the cultural groups that have
been and without question at points in
history subjugated by a dominator
cultures and and the where the dominant
and the the assumption is in our culture
that it's white males and that's a fair
assumption in a northern European
culture but in other cultures probably
it would be different cultural groups
usually male but not always white
because EG China
the assumption is is that by addressing
these uh the demographic balance you can
change the systems themselves and I
don't actually think that it will change
the systems themselves as you know I
think I believe that we really need to
radically evaluate the institutions that
manage and distribute power I don't
think that parliamentary democracy is
ever going to deliver a quality or
fairness whatever word you want I think
they're doing a lot of plaster over
xwinds from what I can tell like in
terms of the women they select let's say
we're looking for uh diversity they just
select like the most masculine women
because power is masculine in the in our
eyes and they just put these Hillary
Clinton or Thatcher or you know what I
mean and it's like it's not really
representative of a woman I know I don't
know any woman like Hillary Clinton or
Thatcher no no I mean thank God by the
way
um
yes I think that um if you're really
interested in change and you're really
interested in fairness and you're really
interested how let's say the majority of
people's lives could be improved I
wonder what type of representation you
want and whether or not it might be
interesting to look at all or in the
systems themselves and the Soviet base
doesn't sound uh vague what I mean is
decentralized power the more people have
the ability to democratically control
their own Regional Community the more
fairness will I think ensue from that
there are examples of it there are
places for example in Brazil I think
it's called saying like Porto Allegro
I'm not the type of person will remember
the exactly or something like that but
where the budget is allocated everyone
has a vote on how the regional budget is
spent is you want to spend on health do
you want to spend it on school do you
want to spend it on roads you want to
spend it on police and they
democratically allocate the budgets with
within that community and this is just
one example of ways that power might
alter because it is truly representative
do you find that more at least
anecdotally as I recall more people
spend money on schools and health than
you might assume because you again
you'll liberating the process from
lobbying and the donor class the
corruption from the corruption
corruption is able to occur more easily
when you centralize power because it can
become more easily expressed in
relationships your agenda and I remember
being 14 years old on on like the
original YouTuber wherever it was and
learning about the New World Order and I
was like what is this but this is what
you've been fighting against like in a
way since I can remember I guess I began
by thinking that socialism is the answer
and what I mean by socialism is fairness
and uh
redistribution of wealth because we have
redistribution of wealth anyway because
we have subsidies of energy companies
all sorts of Industries are subsidized
all sorts of like you know let's think
are the most obvious and glaring example
is in 2008 when the banks crashed they
were subsidized by the taxpayer they
were held together a choice was made not
to facilitate the Financial Security of
the people that lost their homes but the
banks that we had the banks and
financial institutions that it could be
argued created that crisis so we do have
redistribution of wealth anyway so we're
just looking at different types of
redistribution of wealth broadly
speaking I think it's right that Health
Care should be publicly funded that most
people should have access to work and to
facilities and education but what I've
started to think is that when you
centralize these decisions and use
institutionalize these matters it's both
becomes corrupt and it's not able to
accurately refle reflect the vast and
varying requirements of a huge number of
people so I don't agree now that the
state should have that the state should
have should a mass power the only
function of the states will be to
protect people primarily from I would
say corporate corruption the reason I
believe in decentralization is because
I've come to believe that there is so
there are so many ways of Being Human
that you want as much as possible to
defuse Conflict by saying well if you
want to live like that over there then
you should be able to and if you want to
live like that then you should be able
to and as long as people aren't being
oppressed subjugated exploited then
we're gonna have to leave people alone
it's just a very very interesting time
to be alive because there are very there
are a lot of different ways of Being
Human and because of the miracle of
communication we're more aware of it
than we once would have been there was a
time when we would have lived tribally
regionally a unaware blissfully unaware
of the Glorious differences between
different tribes in Iceland and Senegal
and across the world people have all
sorts of ways of Being Human based on
geography based on culture and tradition
and those things I think are wonderful
and they're for to see that they're
homogenization that every High Street
looks the same everyone has the same
kind of views everyone it's the same
kind of food and how is it what's really
behind it every High Street looking the
same we know now it's economic interest
what's behind everyone eating highly
processed food we know now it's economic
interest why are people not sharing the
information that if you didn't eat
processed food heart disease would
radically drop diabetes would disappear
cancer would radically drop while we're
not sure economic reasons so we don't
live without an ideology there is an
ideology it's invisible and it's
Insidious and it's very difficult to
attack it because of these centralized
institutions and the relationship they
have with other centralized corporate
institutions so this the only way to end
that I think is by attacking the
institutions themselves and of course I
believe in fan is I believe that people
regardless of their color their identity
their sexuality their gender or their
sex should be free to become who they
are that's what I'm trying to do I'm
trying to become who I really am I'm
trying to look at where the culture has
been beneficial and nurturing and where
the culture has been an impediment and
that's that's a journey that we can all
share in I'm pretty sure you wouldn't
want me telling you what to do and how
to live your life and I wouldn't want
you telling me look we're different
we've got different ways of Being Human
different assets and I guess we have to
find ways that we can hang together
Loosely and I think that will be a lot
more possible if there isn't so if there
aren't so many centralized biases that
are impossible to address that only
become observable in points of radical
crisis sometimes something happens you
think that's weird that that was
reported on in that way that's where
they didn't tell you that that's weird
that they've tried to conceal that
that's weird that that wasn't addressed
well this you can see the outline of the
corpse because of what you're not told
you can see where the where the power
really is because of what's observable
by its symptoms by its fruits you can
know it now they are the subject of
masculinity and my own masculinity you
know obviously there are Limitless ways
of being male of being female and the
identity conversation that's currently
taking place I guess is and and an
expression of that and I wonder how my
own maleness might have been expressed
if I had been uh if I'd had access to
the kind of discourse around gender and
identity that's going on now but I was
sort of aware of people like David Bowie
and Mark Bolin and like they're in rock
and in entertainment there was a degree
of fluidity and in many cases they were
people from pretty ordinary drab
backgrounds like mine and that's perhaps
no coincidence that you become sort of
interested in glamor and flamboyance if
there's a sort of dreariness in your
environment and I think you're right
that there is a spectrum and a scale of
maleness and uh and of female nurse and
in a way I think so many of the the
cultural arguments that are tying us up
in knots and create in Conflict can be
alleviated removed ameliorated if by
simple Love by simple love like most of
us know people that are very traditional
and sort of conservative most of us know
people they're pretty Progressive you
know like due to the way that
Generations are shifting you're going to
know people that are trans you're going
to know people that are Orthodox
Christian and in a way in if we're all
in the same room and we'll leave one
another alone things tend to go pretty
well what just seems to have changed and
this appears to be significant to me
mate is this piece of analysis we used
to look at things in terms of left and
right this is no longer a helpful
discourse now we should look at things
in terms of the center and the periphery
this comes from the analysis of Martin
Guri a former CIA worker who said that
he noticed while working at the CIA is a
data analyst that in 2001 there was as
much data published that year as there
was in all history up to that point so
in one year as much data and information
was published as in all his up to that
point in 2002 it happened again and then
2008 again and again the amount of
information doubling he said that when
you look at on a graph it looks like a
tidal wave a tidal wave is hitting he
recognized that with information
available and being produced at that
rate it was going to be impossible to
have the kind of centralized narratives
that we'd previously had NBC CNN the
American government the BBC information
is just spilling out it's everywhere
obviously now we have this what is known
as the censorship industrial complex
because it's impossible to just say this
is what's happening in the Ukraine
Russian conflict or this is what
happened during the pandemic well this
is what happened in the Falklands or
this is how JFK was murdered shut up now
we're like hold on a minute what about
all of these things and all of these
facts that doesn't mean that there
aren't crazy crackpot conspiracy
theories out there but it also means
that the idea of crackpot conspiracy
theories is being used to master the
fact that
centralized authoritative media and
government organizations put out
untruthful narratives in order to stop
people generally Uprising and rejecting
systems of power now that we had so he
said look at things in terms of the
center and the periphery so there are
figures on the traditional right that
are peripheral and are attacking the
center there are figures on the left
that are attacking the center the center
widely now is interested in legitimizing
authoritarianism like why can what are
the reasons that we can stop people
speaking freely what are the reasons we
can ask people to we can restrict
people's movement what are the reasons
that we can control people I would
suggest that we will see
crises play out that legitimize the use
of authority in fact I think that that's
already begun to happen and that's sort
of not conspiracy theory Even in our
lifetimes we've had like 9 11 massive
financial crash then we have the sort of
the ongoing political crises obviously
the pandemic and I'm not suggesting that
any of these things are not real or did
not happen of planes they're just
capitalizing right that's basically it
Brian yeah and in terms of what you were
saying about the the left versus the ray
MSNBC you had this huge moment a few
months back which you went on their own
channel and openly just tore them a new
one and it was beautiful no one could
have done it the way you did because you
the way you use humor
to win those battles while inserting so
much information is genius and it's when
I was doing my research on you there
were so many people uh writing articles
about you how the left have lost Russell
and it just made me wonder like how do
you feel about people viewing you as
part of their gang originally when you
were seeing a socialist and now classing
you as being labeled the conspiracy
theorist and the media have I feel
anyway and maybe you'll be more aware
ramped up the the pressure around you
but this guy is a bad guy he is a
conspiracy theorist he's a nutcase he's
he's talking from a shed and he's doing
you know what I mean like they're trying
to make you out as because they're
clearly threatened because your message
is cutting through and you're one of the
few people who has the huge audience but
also sees the dots and can connect them
their economic model is under threatened
because of it is more effective to spend
advertising money with you or me than
them ultimately so they're going to have
to amend and adapt their model that's
primarily what's happening when it comes
to like the labels like left and right I
really believe in individual social
Collective and cultural Justice I
absolutely believe in people's right to
be who they are I believe the biggest
problems and biggest threats to the
world are centralized corporate and
state power and that there's a very
porous relationship between those two
institutions that they could almost be
regarded as one thing I'm talking about
from the power of the pharmaceutical
industry the military industrial complex
and the media and if you look at their
ownership models and the way that they
are that their Shares are apportioned
and the kind of crossover in their
interest and the kind of crossover and
people that have worked within the media
and worked within the government or
worked with the military industrial
complex and then our have had positions
in the American Military for example and
then work in foreign countries
organizing weapons deal between these
companies like lucky Martin Raytheon
Norfolk Grumman Etc you can see see that
there's just sort of one centralized
systemic entity that's based on
economics you don't need to get into
occultism and whether or not weird
stuff's going on whether they put on
dressing down for the crazy self and
clearings in the woods although that
would be wonderful too you just can just
see how power is functioning and
whenever if you critique that stuff and
I do consider myself to be operating on
behalf of the culture and community that
I emerged from which includes the
ordinary working class background that I
come from that includes uh people that
have had mental health and addiction
issues that includes
open-heartedness to progressivism and to
people that identify outside of
conventional heterodox relationships
that's open to people that are
traditional like like for me those
things are important and but what's more
important than them is that the the
people that identify in those ways
traditionally or progressively recognize
that they is going to have to be a new
Union a new Unity otherwise we're going
to see more and more centralized
authoritarianism and less and less
Liberty for everybody that is more
important to find alliances with people
that you typically wouldn't agree with
then sort of babbling down on criticism
and condemnation of those people and I
have noticed of course I have noticed
that I'm being criticized but to tell
you the truth when I was sort of a
darling of those establishments that
weren't particularly great either as
soon as I was ages ago that I wrote that
book Revolution and I'm uh sounds a bit
grandiose to say self-educated but it
haven't been conventionally educated at
IU University or whatever so like even
then when I wrote that book there was a
bit of a how dare you sneer in contempt
I remember when it was when I was first
doing like the truths and talking about
politics and that like the people who
know oh it sounds like Park life the
blur thing and like putting that Phil
Daniels and all right they're saying
because I've got this accent that I
shouldn't be using yeah
I think there is an elitism and like
it's been spoken of course spoken to
quite a lot of the American uh
journalists and analysts they said that
the class of Journalism awkward became
sort of professionalized a lot of people
said that there used to be a kind of
alliance between the what was regarded
as the Intelligentsia and the
proletariat and that has broken down and
you can sort of see it and sense it take
for example a subject like brexit there
was a lot of sort of open disdain for
people in the north for Working Class
People everywhere oh they're idiots
they're racist and stuff like that was
straight away what it was that's the
straightaway the story that we were told
that and and I think that kind of what
backs that is a it has been an ongoing
but veiled disdain for ordinary people
that the the the in a sense that group
is being continually demonize I remember
Owen Jones's book chavs he talked about
like how even that word was an attempt
to sort of revitalize attacking like oh
look at him white violent van man
reunion Jack hanging up in the window
and in a sense it's I mean 50 60 80
years ago who I would just ask the
question primarily from which
communities were conscripted soldiers
drawn from and told oh there's this
thing called Britain that's really
important and it's better than
everything else so we're going to ask
you to die now yeah if that's okay the
queen for the queen and stuff if you
wouldn't mind dying in a trench or in
Eep or in some campaign in northern
France or Belgium as I say England was
pretty real to them then the flag meant
something to them then and if like you
know if you if you have grandparents
that have been in the military if you've
lost people with like because of the
services then understandably your
attitude to pay autism and nation is
going to bear that inflection and like I
would invite people who have that kind
of traditional uh let's call it
traditional for one of an easier word
background to incorporate inclusivity
but I can recognize why them is it's
certainly easy as well to stoke tensions
around immigration that are these people
it's going to be afraid they tell you
that's why you can't get an appointment
at the doctors this is why you can't get
a house this is why you know it's very
interesting but what I try to bring to
the Forefront whenever I can is if you
find yourself not liking people that do
not have any power how can they exact or
enact or bring about change if they
don't have power if people are desperate
whether those are a working class white
people black people or Muslims gay
people whatever or if they're from
another country if they don't have power
how is it that they are orchestrating
anything I think the job comes the job
must be always Brian who is powerful who
is making these decisions who is
benefiting who is controlling media who
is controlling resources who is
controlling information who is
attempting to prevent other information
being conveyed on that basis I think you
can make better critiques and form
better alliances you know when you
mentioned earlier about sort of Bohemian
Grove type stuff yes
um obviously you've you've been learning
a lot
um and it feels like the higher up you
go like the darker it gets and there's
like a suspicious number of you know
billionaire trillionaire pedos out there
so
um or at least we'll let it believe
um how dark do you think it goes the
higher up you go in terms of like
satanic stuff and all of this sort of
stuff I get a bit scared when I think
about it I know people that are kind of
credible academics that say it's legit
and certainly there are some thing some
things that are demonstrably true like
like you remember
um John Ronson and Alex Jones is staff
from like the late 90s around
particularly around Bohemian Grove and
like oh wow group and all of that that's
still happening and people are meeting
up and making decisions but of course I
suppose if there are things like the wef
which appears like a sort of be like a
sort of soft but like soft power green
washing or whatever washing the
movements of the powerful creating
narratives of this is how we're going to
change the world without affecting these
Elite interests
your mother you're gonna have 15-minute
cities and they're going to carry on
flying around in Jets you know like the
promotion of ideas those kind of
Institutions and groups and
organizations evidently do exist there
are people I know that talk about
interdimensional beings and ceremonies
and all of that and I feel that when you
get into that territory unless you can
sort of demonstrate it then this almost
you are arming your opponents so I think
it's like I'm sort of fascinated by this
stuff because it's by its nature
fascinating and on a sort of personal
and spiritual level I do believe that
there are different layers of reality
and that power is drawn from something
other than the material plane and that
spirituality is vital and you can access
within yourself forces they're dormant
and if I think that and if people are
using that for good the rishis the
Saints the sages of the ages or going
into the Laboratories of the spirit and
finding ways of transforming the
experience of being human through
meditation and through breath work and
defying on occasion it appears is the
laws of physics then I'm sure that if
people know that and are using it for
good then possibly those things are
being utilized for more nefarious uh
ends but what we'll say when I spoke to
RFK who is like he's an interesting
figure Robert F Kennedy because he's
like when you see how let's call it the
Legacy Media or the mainstream behaves a
figure like Trump will obviously be
maligned for being libertarian and
right-wing and for the many cultural
social uh things that he's done that are
pretty off key and then a figure like
RFK he'll be attacked for being sort of
anti-vaxx and and in the end if you
think well what is the what are the
lines that we have to operate within
ultimately it's you can choose anyone
between the clintons and the Obamas but
don't move all the all the bushes even
like you've got to stay within some
pretty narrow lines like some of the RFK
who's saying we the CIA should be
disbanded the FBI should be heavily
investigated the way that lobbying and
donations around American politics needs
to be interrogated and the fact is is
that he's did a lot of work around some
of the issues connected to the pandemic
there's pretty thorough and rigorous
when he came on our show I I was
reminded of the phrase like you know in
a Few Good Men you can't handle the
truth I was like blood yeah actually I
don't think I can handle the truth this
is intense he said stuff about the sort
of funding of certain of like you know
the Medical Response he said like the
stuff that he told me about how power
operates and it's sort of all available
in the podcast frightened me it makes me
scared I think there's enough stuff that
can be observed and proven that
strongly suggest we need a radical
appraisal of the way that power
functions at a national and Global level
there's enough without having to get
into all of that stuff about occultism
and occultism and the various Affiliated
more radical issues I can see why people
are interested in it
because it's scintillating and exciting
but even a figure like Epstein it seems
that the criminality around uh sex and
sex trafficking is secondary to some of
the financial ties and financial
corruption and financial relationships
and even possibly that the trafficking
stuff is possibly being promoted in
order to prevent us from looking at some
of the financial ties there's some
pretty important and powerful people
Bill Gates for example what did you mean
by that the picture of them that came
out it seems that they that Bill Gates
was in a position to be able to uh sorry
that whichever Epson was in a position
to be able to Blackmail Bill Gates and
that there will have been numerous
meetings not just one and that in itself
is not criminal and I'm certainly not
alleging that it is but I uh I um you
know a convicted sex trafficker having
that kind of access is it seems pretty
in interesting and he obviously had
relationships with a lot of very
powerful people I heard Bill Clinton was
on his plane non-stop from the records
like 20 odd times something like that
seems to be a matter of record and I
wonder what the case is for the Legacy
Media for not exploring those ideas
although you know we don't know what
they're up to what we do know is people
like George Bush I'll go all were in the
same club together at school and have
this uh you know secret thing that
they're not allowed to talk about and
then you've got uh Boris and bloody
David Cameron and all them at the same
the different different countries same
exact thing I heard from from Jordan
Peterson and don't assume malfeasance
when ineptitude will do so don't assume
that they're doing something wicked if
it's just enough that they'll be if
they're inept but if you think of some
of the things that came out through
Hancock's WhatsApp messages and uh as I
understand Boris Johnson's messages it
seems that like if we know own some of
the things that we know now just about
their response to coronavirus whether
it's the potential origin from a
laboratory the lack of trials for
transmission the promotion of the idea
that your personal
um whether or not you made a choice to
take the medications or not had an
implication towards other people
and I'm not even sure if you can say
this yet on YouTube that in 96 of
Casey's people that were asymptomatic
could not and were not infectious could
not spread the disease and were not
infectious all of this kind of
information that there was a type of
test available that was able to
ascertain whether or not you were
infectious much earlier in the process
that the information about how effective
lockdowns were going to be like you know
these are all things that um it was not
handled in a sanguine and calm way
truthful information was censored on
social media we know that that's [__]
yeah and it's only a couple of years ago
and it's almost like time itself is
getting faster and our ability to just
oh well we've moved on now it's like
that there are people that are still in
the environs of political power Boris
Johnson for example lobbying for further
expenditure in the ongoing conflict
between Ukraine and Russia that it feel
to me like they might be demonstrably
corrupt people and the we even the fact
that those ongoing parties took place at
a time when every single person you know
presumably didn't go to a funeral or
attend the birth of a child or like you
know or say goodbye to their loved ones
say goodbye to their loved ones who died
as a result of coronavirus and like the
impact on mental health and potential
people taking their own lives and
addiction and alcoholism and the impact
on children's learning all of these
things suggest once again for me
decentralized power let people vote on
this stuff for God's sake of people's
determine for themselves did you see the
head of well the old head of Twitter or
whatever being questioned in court where
the judge goes so did you knowingly
silence doctors and yeah well why well
we were told to by the government
what this is a doctor who was are you
are you a doctor no so this doctor is an
expert is putting out valuable truthful
information and you are silencing them
at the orders of the government and that
was like in court that's pretty powerful
it's insane also people being called
anti-vaxx antivaxis they invented
vaccines advocated for vaccination until
vaccines said perhaps this could be used
a a little more uh consciously and
judiciously are there certain
communities that are more at risk are
there certain cases where this would be
more beneficial than others where it'd
be less I can't help but feel Brian that
what was revealed there is that the
state likes to regulate and legislate
and the and control I.E that is the
point of government is to govern and
that certain Industries benefited hugely
financially there was a five trillion
dollar wealth transfer during that
period it created a new billionaire
every day it gave it granted more power
to some of the most powerful
institutions in the world big Tech big
Pharma the media all benefited from it I
can you divorce those discernible facts
from the decisions that were made and if
you can then that's all good also what
do you think the biggest lie that was
told around corvid was to us what I
thought that with the biggest
transgression was is that at the very
beginning people naturally and
understandably acknowledge that there is
a sanctity to human think about what
underwrites the idea of two meters apart
Mars lockdown all life is sacred and we
must all protect and love one another
that's what we hear we're here to love
one another we don't want to cause other
people to suffer or cause other people
to be sick do you agree with that yes
right okay well then all of the
decisions are based on that but where
else in our society do you see that as
the mindset that's playing out oh I
would remember all life sacred and we're
all here to take care of each other so
let's can I help you in any way remember
those glaring and garish examples in
this city that they housed homeless
people like oh we kind of homeless
people they get them all in hostels
right Kobe's over get back in at the end
of it so like firstly they revealed that
homelessness could be instantaneously
solved and then that it was not
convenient to continue doing it all the
while the people that were making those
decisions were continuing to have what I
think were pretty [__] parties based
primarily around cheese while that was
happening a lot was revealed it revealed
a lot that's what I feel homeless people
they're the ones who really got the
right on the deal they're like me I wish
corvid would kick in again well that was
sweet that was a good deal
yeah a little bit of respect but there
was also a lot of fear-mongering wasn't
there and I think that that also helped
them control us and it I'm not saying I
agree with uh David Ike on a lot of
things but the one thing that I took my
and I started going down that rabbit
hole when I was a teenager learning
about all these theories there is was
odor out of chaos you bring the chaos
but then you bring in the laws you
benefit from them and the more scared
and confused you can keep people the
more easier it is to have your wicked
way with them and it that really was
summed up yes and problem reaction
solution yeah which I think was a phrase
coined by Chomsky and we just like this
is why this is for me Inseparable from
what I would call for the
psychosimplicity spirituality because if
you are frightened you are malleable
think about when you're fronting your
own life and essentially I know myself
when I'm afraid I Look to Authority like
please help me please show me what to do
and he's the sheep and a sheepdog right
yeah yeah and if that Authority is
corrupt then that is not good and I
think we live at a time potentially I'm
talking primarily about American
politics but I I guess it will come to
apply here no one has any faith in the
electoral system no one has anything
faith in the justice system no one has
any faith in the media and it feels like
we're at risk of losing faith in one
another in the next American election I
believe it's next year if the Democrats
win do you imagine for a moment that the
Republicans are going oh well done or
vice versa that's over and the reason
that that's over is because it's he said
Martin Guri in that book The Revolt of
the public in which he offered the new
systems of categorization Center versus
periphery rather than left versus right
that new alliances will be formed he
said that because of the way that the
world has changed because of Technology
because of the ability to communicate
it's suggesting new decentralized models
might emerge naturally and organically
that power should be as close to the
people affected by it as possible that
we should regionalize and break down
power structures wherever we can and
look at the where possible how our
systems of power have been biased by
Elite and establishment interests oh
this is the reason we eat this kind of
food oh this is the reason that we
regulate in that way or this is the
reason that that kind of Regulation is
not applied that a new order is
ironically trying to be born there is a
decentralized democratic
localized where it's we're being told
continue it's clear in nature a very
obvious way to understand it I think is
in the food that we eat Brian that we
all know now that we were not evolved to
have high access to sugar and fat so
when you do have a lot of access to
sugar and fat it's not generally
speaking very good for you because it
was a scarcity to find a sugar-rich
fruit in the conditions for which we
evolved for millions of years in harmony
with nature it usually in groups that
had one purpose survive survive together
we have to cooperate and have
relationships with one another in order
to survive your environment becomes all
automatically sacred you're allergic
with one another becomes automatically
sacred you are not separate from nature
you evolved and harmonized from nature
now of course we live in a kind of zoo
we live in cubes we have access to
resources we have access to information
much of which we do not act upon so we
eat much more sugar than we ought much
more fat than we ought we most of us
know now we would be better off if we
ate whole food that had been grown or
caught in the case of those of you that
eat meat near where you are now in this
at the time that it is now curiously
that's what's generally speaking better
it would improve most people's thoughts
radically to eat food grown where they
are and to eat animals if you eat
animals obviously don't but like around
where you are that is possible that you
could reorganize Society in our systems
to go all right well let's try to grow
as much food as possible trade only
where necessary not mass-produced food
in order to generate as much profit as
possible not push upon people the kind
of foods that are highly profitable and
basically addictive in many cases when
it comes to fast food that information
is available why are we not acting on
that knowledge why are we not acting on
that knowledge and where else do you
imagine that anthropology holds the key
to how we might live differently that
we're not supposed to be living in
groups of millions and millions of
people that that should only be the case
where necessary in certain logistical
Municipal cases oh it would be good to
centralize roads and security and maybe
some aspects of Judiciary and law
enforcement but it has to be as
Democratic as possible and democracy
means that there might be people nearby
that live in a way that's that is not
appealing to you that's what democracy
might actually mean what value is
tolerance and open-mindedness if it
means I I don't believe in other
people's freedom I don't believe in
other people's freedom of expression it
has no value at all and it seems to me
I'm not like a technological utopian
like some of the most influential
figures in our time now like Elon Musk
but I believe that technology could be
utilized to create conditions more in
alignment with how we have evolved to
live rather than all reordering the way
we lived to it till it's sort of
unrecognizable of course the process of
civilization is taking our kind out of
nature so that we can control resources
and survive we can survive the weather
we can survive scarcity of food I'm not
suggesting wouldn't it be great if we
lived in caves and we're covering [__]
the whole time that's what I'm
advocating for saying that's recognize
that the magnetic force the power behind
most of our institutions and systems is
a centralizing one that only really
adapts evolves yields or concedes
anything when it's absolutely necessary
and even then it's the smallest possible
compromise you can see that with all the
most significant changes whether it's
their sort of the Socialist movement in
this country all right have a weekend or
I have an hospital or I have a school
but many retirement
sorry man you can have a little mini
what I do Friday right a retire from a
job I have like a little carriage clock
and everything and everyone gathers
around and like give a speech about what
and then on Monday the retirement ends
I've seen your video on that and I was
[__] laughing man so hard you know
you mentioned Elon Musk to me he's a
fascinating guy because he does seem to
be trying to do some good in the world
what what do you what do you think is
intentions are he really believes in
technology and he believes that we can
solve all of Earth's problems through
technology through things like neuralink
and through colonizing space and like
all sorts of other stuff and he's so
obviously brilliant and vast that he has
a about you know he has a vision based
on technology that we can continue to
manage resources he thinks that the
population's a bigger popular a bigger
problem than overpopulation the the
Earth won't run out of resources and I
I'm generally speaking fascinated by
Elon Musk I think he's fascinated yeah
the depopulation thing is really
interesting because I was looking into
some stats and in terms of like babies
being born marriages every fertility I
seen you did a clip on that it's it's
plummeting yeah and you know like people
don't want to get married and have kids
anymore like even if you want to
fertility's down Mission Wonder like
where are we headed I always was of a
mind that oh maybe it would be good if
there were less people over time and
life would become more sacred and we
would care for one another obviously
that comes with enormous demographic
challenges like an aging population a
small Workforce and stuff but I've
always what fascinates me is real
radical change in order to create a
better more awakened and conscious world
and how that might be achieved through
the autonomous decisions of individuals
acting collectively rather than imposed
from the top down by some corrupt evil
centralized Force when you talk about
the fertility that obviously has there's
a dietary and toxin implication there
like what the expert that I spoke to
what's her name shanesson I spent the
whole interview thinking shanya Twain
Shania Twain so now that I have to
actually remember I'm
like she said that you can't have a 50
decline in fertility without there being
some external Factor yeah that's just
too much of a radical change I feel we
need to address the way that we eat the
way that we work the all of it I think
everything's up for review I don't know
if I agree and sort of like we're at
some apocalyptic moment because we all
are individually we're all going to die
so the personal pocket does it matter if
everyone else in the world dies at the
same time as you who knows maybe maybe
not but I do feel that this does seem
like a time as such this retention and
disruption and sadness and awareness of
unfairness and that there is an
opportunity for radical reevaluation and
it's going to involve technology but I
think more importantly Spiritual
Awakening at the level of an individual
it is mind-blowing that 50
of have gone down and fertility and no
one's that should be everywhere I mean
the only person I've heard even mention
it is you yeah and that should be like
what the hell is going on what is wrong
with this this is a massive problem we
need to sort this out and it's business
as usual when these things aren't openly
discussed it does create an environment
where conspiracy becomes viable and
certainly something that's worth
contemplating the question I always
consider myself is when it comes to the
category of top secret with like say
government documentation what do you
imagine that accumulative library of top
secrecy is made up of the revelations of
Edward Snowden would strongly suggest
that the vast majority of it is
information that demonstrates how the
government often acts against the
interests of the population they were
elected to serve and whose taxis pay for
their work of course some of it is about
protecting EG American or UK interest
from potential external Bad actors but I
think most of us are starting to think
that top secret basically means stuff
that if you knew it you would stop
complying then when you look at what do
you imagine lobbying money does the
money the vast sums spent by enormous
Global conglomerates to impact and
influence the way that regulation is
imposed around stuff like diet and food
do you imagine that that lobbying money
is like look we're just trying to feed
him the best food possible and if only
look here's some money just usually if
you have to bribe someone to do
something it's not for a good reason
it's not for a good reason so the whole
of tops you know the vast majority of
information that's sort of clandestine
is information that if you knew it you
would refuse to cooperate the vast
majority of money that's spent on
lobbying and donations to political
parties is to enable and encourage those
that are politically powerful to act
against the interests of the population
that they were elected to serve and in
favor of the interests of corporate
entities I'm not saying what's Difficult
about stuff like this is I know that
there'll be countless people working in
the industries of big Pharma and food
that are well-intentioned loving people
when I was on the other side of as it
were of this kind of argument I like I'm
perhaps would have been naive about
subjects like the military if you know
everyone that worked like this in the
military they're just interested in
controlling the population or everyone
that works in the police now I know that
there are people like it that a lot of
people in the police force are Community
or in Aid could be because I personally
know people in the police force that are
just delightful and lovely and I know
loads of people that are in the military
and Military vets and loads of people in
the fire service and loads of people in
teaching professions that really care
and are trying their best and people
that are nurses and people that are
doctors that believe in community and
believe and people in science they are
it's not about the object and it's not
about the issue it's that there is an
Insidious and invisible force that is
I'm not talking to Coliseum or mystery
that is just about dominion and
financial gain that is incrementally
influencing every single issue and it's
the sort of corralling us into a tiny
and unmanageable space now so all of
these resources can be unlocked the
Ingenuity of scientists and technicians
The Bravery of people in the four forces
the Good Will of people in the teaching
profession the kindness of nurse all
these things these resources that are
there these are the things that we
should enshrine that we should Elevate
that we should celebrate that we should
regulate and legislate in order to
facilitate not all of the time do the
opposite of that so the Payless free you
look at the NHS already you could see
the you know like it's being privatized
they've been passing bills without
telling us for like the last 10 years
that are slowly and episodically handing
over more and more power to private
interest we saw that happen again during
the pandemic perhaps it's just a
coincidence that a hugely profitable
Endeavor was rolled out without you
scrutiny but just look elsewhere in
society and see if you can see patterns
around the accumulation of wealth and
power and see if it makes sense to you
that the aim that's behind these things
is human life is sacred we've got to
protect one another at all costs we love
one another see if that tracks for you
as an individual really what we're
inviting people to do bribe of you and I
hope is is to use the information that's
available to you to make decisions for
yourself and to recognize that don't
that you can't go crazy as a result of
it you have to hold yourself together
and stay grounded and know that
something beautiful is possible that
change is possible all of this is being
undertaken optimistically sometimes I
feel like when I'm doing all these
videos and I'll talk about how corrupt
they are not that I feel like oh no
really it's going to generate Despair
and I know what it's like to be in this
world and to be lonely and to be
depressed and feel like you've got you
don't have enough and that your life's
not going anywhere and you can't trust
anyone you can't trust any institutions
and you've been divorced from all
meaning and in the end just some Friday
night down the big Market puking up the
brown is gonna be enough for you but
there's more there's something glorious
there's something glorious available to
us wherever you are in some dumb
downtown Southern privilege Province
somewhere if you've been romp-fooded off
or you've been hulled with an inch of
your life there is a new community a new
dawn there is an Awakening available for
you it's available wow Russell you're
[__] amazing kid you are amazing
um you know when you were talking about
in regards to
you know centralized power and the
invisible forces that work for me it's
never been more obvious though when
you've got this bimbling old fool uh in
charge in America in charge in Joe Biden
you know the guy can barely string a
sentence together bless him and yet once
upon a time we used to look at the
president of the United States as
someone who is in charge the ruler the
person who is the leader of the Free
World and now it's just so obvious that
he's basically just wheeled out uh are
you in terms of voting you once were
very uh controversial you said don't
vote and then obviously you changed your
mind what's your opinion about voting
now it's a bit like what I was saying
about progressivism and trying to create
new institutions I in a sense rejects
the framing I was never saying that
people shouldn't be participating in
democracy there's nothing more important
than you could do than participate in
democracy I was merely pointing out and
in retrospect I think correctly due to
the subsequent Ferrari that you are not
invited to meaningfully participate in
democracy because if you were you would
be able to make meaningful institutional
constitutional radical communal change
and that's simply not on offer here are
some significant things Joe Biden in a
speech to donors from the financial
industry prior to his election said
nothing will meaningfully change nothing
will change that's sort of all you need
to know so it's irrelevant after all the
Sturm and Drang and propaganda are an
excitement around like we've got to get
rid of Donald Trump this guy's a monster
he's a gargoyle you know without
acknowledging that much of his rhetoric
and his sort of his ability to
communicate in a way that's humorous and
human astonishingly at accessed a lot of
people and erode the emotional Timbre of
the nation in a way that ordinary
politicians were unable to when you're
offered a career politician who's part
of the machine as being part of that
machine for all of their life who has
pledged that nothing will change it's
difficult to invite people to feel
optimistic it's difficult to unless you
focus them intensely on one or two
issues one or two issues and we know
which ones they usually are gun
ownership pro-life pro-choice and more
laterally issues around identity this is
what I think the most valuable thing we
can do is to invite people to form
alliances into like where are you
willing when I went on to Ben Shapiro's
show and a lot of people oh you
shouldn't go on Ben Shapiro because he's
right wing but Ben Shapiro is plainly
like a traditional person whose ideology
is derived from his religious values
Orthodox Jew so that's what that's what
uh or from where he gets his values and
his principles and his mindset I said to
him would you recognizing now the how
erupt the central uh let's call it
political class has become be willing to
be part of a movement for
decentralization and true democracy that
meant that you would be able to run your
own community democratically and if in
your case I mean or you know on the
principles of Orthodox Judaism would you
stand on a platform with people that
were full into the black lives matter
movement or fall into lgbtq plus
movement of four into the conversation
around trash would you be on a platform
with them and say like you know right
our group fully believes that their
problems are you know the issues that
came to the Forefront after the murder
of George Floyd our group believes that
the problems are fully about the sort of
Oppression of the truth of the
complexity of gender identity and our
movement on the case of Ben Shapiro is
all around sort of all Orthodox Judaism
and that we have a set of values based
on the Old Testament and a Torah and the
scriptures the Jewish people we want to
live according to that and what we all
want to do is we want to vote again
against the Republican and Democrat
Party this centralized bipartisan
complex in order that we can run our own
communities in accordance with our own
values you know as described
regionalized I suppose he said yeah of
course I accept he said that I am not
sovereign of Earth and that there are
people that want to live different and I
think that we by rejecting the
possibility that people want to live
differently from us and that we have no
right actually to impose our beliefs on
other people we
I said but we forego the possibility of
rural democracy and real Community by
handing over to in a sense an outdated
and outmoded you know in the case of
America constitutional republic or in
our case whatever the hell this thing is
based on the Magna Carta or whatever why
are we pretending that we need to send
someone off on Horseback from tyneside
to London to represent the views of a
community when now everyone's got
devices they can vote for vex factor or
American Idol or whatever just
immediately why are we not investigating
the possibility of real democracy the
maximum amount of power as close as
possible to the people affected by it so
for example Russell sorry
are you meaning like um in the event of
a lockdown we're gonna have a vote
everyone getting your phones you ready
yeah why not yeah why not
why not allow people to determine for
themselves of course the argument that
had to be mobilized was all because it's
going to affect other people now like in
a sense when it comes to the
intervention what do you want there to
be an authority that can intervene in
the case where you think a child is
being mistreated by their family I
suppose you would want that to happen so
okay so we do want some judicial and law
enforcement I think most people wouldn't
say is up to a family to if they
maltreat a child that's in their care or
not so I guess with the you know but the
fact that there is some complexity to it
doesn't mean that we can't investigate
it because every all of the arguments
that are offered are essentially
conservative arguments they are
essentially leaving the same except for
give us more ability to regulate you
possibly for climate change type reasons
or pandemic type reasons don't break
down our media industrial complex or our
censorship industrial complex don't
start investigating the way that
politics is funded and breaking like he
said to me Janis farafakis who's a you
know a communist I believe he describes
himself as he was of one of the leaders
of Sarita after the financial crash in
Greece they won the election in Greece
they were the biggest party the EU
called them in
and said okay so are you going to be
running Greece and I feel like that what
Sarita ran on was we ain't paying back
them bank loans we ain't paying it back
with the people who voted on and this is
our policy we ain't paying it back and
the as I understand it from Janice
varifakis it was the deputy leader the
dude that was a leader was like man I'm
going with you lot and sort of reneged
on the Mandate given to the people and
sold out his man that's how Janice verif
sells it but he said that when he was
meeting with the EU all of like the
financial bods and the people in charge
he realized they had no power because
their power is the power their role
affords them they don't have like that
guy couldn't go do you know what don't
pay us back like he has to go you're
gonna pass back otherwise we're gonna
impose all sorts of legislature machine
legislature and Machinery on Greece to
bloody well make sure that as our man
Foucault will tell you all laws are
ultimately underwritten by violence like
whether it's you know don't park here
I'm gonna Park here here is a parking
Vine I'm not paying it you've got a date
to attend court I'm not coming knock
knock some geezers are at the door
sooner or later yeah if you bro the law
is underwritten by violence it is no
coincidence that even the most seemingly
innocuous ceremonies like a coronation
are surrounded by a militaristic imagery
and and I suppose visual emblems of
power and wealth in order to undergird
the idea that this is somehow right and
just and ain't going nowhere the
ludicrous conversation about not wearing
mad garters and suspenders because it's
out of touch the whole thing is out of
touch the whole thing is out of touch
and I'm not an anti-royal person
actually I'm a pro-reality person a pro
let's look at what we're doing with our
resources and what we're doing with our
time and what our values are as a
culture and where it's important for us
to be what is it you know like uh oh
Gandhi says this amazing thing that like
you know firstly Freedom at the level of
the individual and responsibility at the
level of the family then the family is
responsible to the community and the
community can be responsible to the
region and the region responsible to the
nation and the nation response to the
world not the other way around not the
world there's this one sort of elite
strata of power upside down in it it's
upside down mate no one wants that but
like because our tour is a comic you
know I go to do a gig in Newcastle or do
a gig in Luton welcome
get ready for a touch of reality going
into Kenilworth Road people it seems to
me basically want to be left alone
people want to be left alone just leave
me alone let me get on with what I'm
doing most people actually don't want to
hurt other people most people don't care
what your religion and they're like
isn't stoking all this crap up all the
time getting people in an unnecessary
further and thinking about what you were
saying about the royal family I mean
seeing that they spend 200 million on
the Queen's funeral I mean funerals can
be pricey but that's very pricey for the
public to be paying up
um it's a bit steeper uh what was the
[__] casket made out of gold
um and and seeing your journey as
everyone will call you the comic the
sugar to now Family Man dad husband
and leaving all of that behind what what
made you do that 180 because I'm lucky
that I'm in recovery from drugs and
alcohol 20 years congratulations thank
you very much mate so I'm I'm able with
help because I belong to support groups
and I'm a member of a community it's
actually a decentralized community
that's run fully democratically where no
one is more important than anyone else
and whether we have a shared shared goal
to awaken and to be of service to others
knowing that we will slip up and fail
but we'll help one another through with
this salvation Redemption believing in
the good values that religion has given
us I'm able to look at what my conduct
is about really if I'm obsessively in or
obsessively looking at pornography or
obsessively gambling like anything
that's generates dopamine is possible to
get addicted to
so I'm able to look at like is what is
this lifestyle giving you is this
healthy what's the impact of this and
I'm able to make changes based on
firstly on being aware of it
and
I suppose a traditional institution like
the family
gives you something it gives you
something it gives you obviously
stability and security
it may not be for everybody the idea of
living in a family and certainly
actually I've got a lot of questions
about it myself there seems to be a lot
of I inhered ideas within the nuclear
family this is not a new critique it's
one of the enduring feminist critiques
that the family can be quite oppressive
and that it's the women's rights can be
consumed and submerged within a family
and also that perhaps even on a more
practical level
children can be raised better in a group
I mean can you explain your Dynamics I
understand pretty traditional I mean we
live in a house I've got two kids you
know like and we've got too many pets
and like I work my wife works as well
but like I have the the financial
responsibility primarily is with me and
the responsibility for raising the
children's primarily of her but
obviously there's a total crossover I
feel like the biggest thing like the
most important thing in my life is
trying to find ways to be with them and
to my responsibility is to let them be
who they really are and trying to remain
vigilant for my the ways that I impose
myself on them and of course none of us
by definition are aware of what our
unconscious traits are and I am lucky to
have mentors when it comes to fathering
and being in a family and in fact all
aspects of my life I turn to people in
my regular moments of uncertainty and
say well I don't know what to do I don't
know how to handle this I thought it's
like you know like anybody I think it
can be oppressive and difficult to be in
a family and to feel the weight of that
responsibility because it is a way as
well as being an incredible blessing and
unless I can get myself to that place of
acceptance which is it gets deep fast
Brian my life is not my life I am in a
life I am in Limitless space right now
somewhere between the cosmological
infinite and the infantissimily small
particles or subparticles of which
material rarely is constituted that have
stopped obeying the laws of Newtonian
physics without anyone saying that it
was okay for them to simultaneously be
in one place simultaneously or both or
neither according to the famous double
slit experiment
I'm in the midst of this believing
myself to be an individual now the idea
that my life is mine and that my day
belongs to me and I should be getting
pleasure and getting power and all of
that that's an idea it's in fact the
defining idea of our time that's an
individualism materialism these are the
ideas that sort of are threaded and
laced throughout our society these are
offered to us as a palliative and a
Panacea you'll be all right if you do
this what is Commerce what is the
advertisement industry other than you
should get this thing and you'll be
better and you're worth it and actually
you're not really good enough look at
them they're better than you but if you
were to do this that's the whole way
that this ongoing Behemoth generates its
Vitality is telling us that we're not
enough and we'll be better if we had
this thing now if you the thing that
about getting clean from drugs and
alcohol is when you look at in the way
that I was granted is it's not about you
give up drugs and alcohol you give up
the person there was a addicted to drugs
and alcohol he's dead he's gone now but
much of me Remains the field of
potential that is consciousness the raw
material the Prima material of being
itself the Consciousness that you
participate in that I participate in
that as far as we know everyone is
participating in this remains and it is
it is plastic and it is malleable you
can make your life into different things
using the material of awareness of
Consciousness I can make myself into a
greedy and selfish person sometimes that
is what happens to me the urges of the
body the urges of their what we call for
for simplicity's sake the ego I want
this I don't want that the religion of
my preferences is always ready to go if
I relinquish the religion of my
preferences oh I don't know what I want
I don't know anymore it doesn't make
sense to me I keep making mistakes the
whole time I give up I Surrender I
Surrender God you take your my life is
yours God do with me what you will do
with me things kind of get easier and a
different Power becomes available so a
reason I'm telling you all that when
it's like you're saying who makes the
breakfast is is because like if I don't
have access to that I go mad I go mad in
any life none of it makes sense to me
because none of it makes sense there's
no reason there's nothing in our
Evolution that would suggest that we
have the equipment to live in a city of
eight million people doing podcasts
where are we deriving all of this from
is extraordinary unless you have access
to something that feels real and it for
me it does come down to these Sesame
Street things I know I can use long
words and get a little esoteric
sometimes but it does come down to Nan
values grandmother values grandfather
values you know what they told you you
know be kind to other people think about
others you just don't be so bloody
stupid you know be kind you're a member
of a community help one another these
simple ideas are the basis for all
Society what is that otherwise what is
it compete and even the early ideas of
Darwin ISM which have been utilized to
naturalize a bunch of values that I
don't think are helpful for us I.E um
notably competition survival of the
fierce there's a lot of other things in
nature Harmony nature is primarily
Harmony
nature is it is an amorphous symbiotic
entity that we're living on the Gaia
Theory famously of James Lovelock God
Rest his soul this is one interconnected
entity that's expressing itself in
various ways it's expressing its self
ornithologically through marine biology
is expressing itself through botany is
expressing itself through Humanity one
force one interconnected Force you can
tell it's one thing it's literally on
one rock in Infinite Space to endlessly
indulge the idea of separateness the
level of the individual the level of the
nation it's an illusion you have to
believe it separate right now my cells
are on their own without my bidding
regenerating my the digestive system my
respiratory system all operating
basically all automatically I'm
breathing in the air that's around me
the idea that I'm separate from you is a
it's true to a degree but not absolutely
true where are we both going to be in a
thousand years time the sales that make
up me and the sales that make up you and
whatever the energy of Consciousness is
where will that be in a thousand years
given that we know that energy cannot be
created or destroyed that it only
changes there are only changes the your
individual self my individual self are
temporary Illusions if you live in a
temporary illusion you cannot be happy
you can be distracted you can be you can
be
pleasured but you can't be happy because
it isn't real the deepest truth is
unitary that we are one and Oneness what
is love other than oh yeah we're
actually the same thing I really love
drinking this water I really love West
Ham United I really love those shoes I
want to be one with it I want to be
connected with it so when I'm living
with my whether I'm living my life as a
family or whether I'm living as a
promiscuous and visual the the fact is
for me it's easier to access the idea of
unity through Duty and responsibility I
suppose rather than the hedonic pursuit
of the appetites if the appetites are
your ultimate goal if really your goal
is privileged Prestige pleasure then you
know you will perhaps learn as I did
that it is not successful it feels like
that detached
um enlightened feeling that you're sort
of around and you're striving for always
to not let yourself get dragged into the
the worst things of Life the pleasure
seeking and stuff like that that's also
kind of it odds a little bit with being
a father because being a father is very
attached being you know you have that
child that literally looks up to you
from day one and relies on you and you
have these um animalistic feelings of
protector provider and carer and on the
one hand you're trying to be this
enlightened person
um how do you sort of balance that of
being that guy for them they say God has
no grandchildren that they have their
connection with God I have my connection
with God for this you know the Oneness
the unity
so of course I'm attached to them
but you know on a school trip you can be
a parent that goes on a school trip
right the the best possible motivation
and I can't you know I don't even want
to reflect on what the other motivations
could be for volunteer putting yourself
forward to be one of the parents that
goes on a school trip do you want to
hang out with your kid I've done it for
my kids school they go ah you know we're
going to Tiggy Winkles fantastic Tiggy
Winkles best little animal rescue center
in the world why is it rescues uh any
Wildlife you take a pigeon or a rat or a
blade bat or anything there the best to
be a indigenous creature of the you know
I mean a natural creature from nature
they'll take care of it brilliant
organization swans and robins and crows
and everything it's beautiful school
trip there that day oh you can't uh
going I arrived there you know to be one
of the parents with me a little sandwich
in that and like I'm a parent on a
school trip oh my God you know it's
weird I love this story about you I had
to go Tiggy Winkles well there were two
school buses and they and I was gonna
get on the bus with my kid right but
they go oh no you aren't allowed on the
bus with your kid why and I went oh
because in the event of a car crash you
would prioritize the rescue of your
child over the other children I was like
well hold on a minute so this bit of
Regulation is based on we're all we're
in Carnage the cabasa's crashed we're at
the side area everyone there's death
there's Decay there's blood the horn and
the wheels are still spinning I'm sort
of blessedly survived this terrible
terrible collision and I see my kids and
now I'd step over them do I all these
little five-year-old decisions we've got
to grind them out I'll grab that one's
kidney for later like of course I mean
my my connection to my children is gonna
my child is gonna play a part but
I'd rescue as many as I possibly could
didn't seem like a very good way to
proceed with a school trip if you ask me
not to mention the fact that in a way
that institutions are can be a problem
an institution is anything where there's
a set of rules a staff an agreement you
know an ideal you know like an
institution is a pretty broad definition
if you look at education what is
education broadly for let's say in our
country to prepare the children for the
labor market how does it primarily do
this by encouraging conformity in a
variety of ways and on the side you
might pick up a bit of maths or woodwork
or something but mainly we're preparing
you for the labor market and we want you
to be compliant I'm not suggesting that
teachers and head teachers and people
that work in the bureaucracies around
education aren't well intentioned
because I meet them all the time and
they're [__] fantastic and God knows
it's a difficult job in those especially
that big six-week holiday right in the
middle of the summer that must be
knackering I love teachers I love
teachers but like you find in what a mad
way is that the best way to bring up
children shouldn't they be getting
brought up differently what are we
trying to do here what are we trying to
achieve so like even being a parent even
going on a school trip putting a kid in
a school you're confronted with so many
questions if you are fundamentally a
person that questions stuff it's a rough
road sometimes because nothing some
sometimes nothing makes sense either of
your children as inquisitive as you do
you think do you see any of that in them
because I can imagine teachers having a
hard time with a little youth especially
because I've primarily told them that
Above All Else always always question
authority never ever accept it just on
the don't ever accept a views out of
what I took all and what I was taught
Anarchist calisthenics Anarchist
calisthenics means break rules every day
just to remember that it's possible not
rules that would hurt people that's
taken care of of another by another
principle kindness love do as to others
all do unto others all of that but don't
just automatically do what you're told
challenge it investigate it why am I
being told to do that for what reason by
whom who benefits so yeah they probably
are difficult to educate they're
certainly difficult to raise because
their answer to things like
would you please clear up your plate and
go to bed is [__] off
why should I trust you who are you where
did you get your Authority from why am I
listening to you so if you raise your
children to be radical you will pay a
price soon or later a couple of things
that's coming up for you before promo
before we wrap up Brian demick uh I love
the word uh Russell's comedy special you
can pre-order tickets available now uh
premieres on the 25th of June and we'll
put the link for that in the description
below you're an amazing performer thanks
mate love it and uh also you've got a
community
um Three Day Festival in uh here on how
do you say that the border between
England and Wales part of it is the
river why there's this campsite where we
went on a camping holiday during the
pandemic we went camping obviously like
everyone we had such a good time there
and the bloke who ran it Aubry was so
lovely we're like why don't we do a
festival here and then we did a festival
last year and Wim off cam
and like now this year like more people
are coming here on Gracie he's coming in
there there's some proper good yoga
teachers breath work teachers but also
people that are pretty politically
radical like that guy Kelly means who
told me all this stuff about the food
industry so it's a free day event uh
like camping Festival really around
wellness and radicalism and exploring
what community might mean so yeah so if
you can't afford it because it's a
couple hundred equipment all the money
goes to drug addicts and alcoholics we
don't keep none the money we give it to
we give it to like Charities we support
our Friendly House in L.A that's a
women's Treatment Center BAC O'Connor
it's a treatment center in Burton on
Trent and Trevi in Plymouth that helps
women they've got kids get into recovery
so we're trying to support good things
with it I mean that that's amazing and
it just shows right that that you can do
no good sometimes because when I was
researching you there was some woman who
wrote a miserable article about it as if
you're some grifter and I'm like he's
doing this for charity love yeah what is
wrong with you
um
I think it's in the end
is it the result of an investigation and
then oh my god I've just done this
investigation this is grift or do you
start with I'm gonna write something bad
that was clearly can I the agenda well I
could say this it's expensive like in uh
there you go I mean perhaps I try to
myself think am I what am I doing when
i'm critiquing government and power do
you know what I'm trying to do I keep
forgetting to do it I'll try and think
this I'm grateful for the people that
built the institutions of government I'm
grateful for the people that built the
institutions of media because now these
institutions are there and all that
needs to change is the mindset behind
them and that's possible we can do that
at the level of the individual so a
revolution in Consciousness will change
all things it will change all things so
instead of like being cynical about them
and like oh I hate all these military
industrial complex censorship industrial
complex the machine I hate them instead
of that thank you thank you for
everything you've done so far now it is
a new time a new Awakening a different
order now so I'm going to try and do
that because even obviously I can be
quite cynical and pursue my own agenda
when it comes to relaying information to
be you know to attack The Establishment
so maybe there's something I can learn
from that and also my show is on Rumble
every day that's uh it's on five o'clock
in our country and you know depending on
time zones elsewhere but it's a one hour
long show where it's news and interviews
and just skullduggery really rumbles on
the up mate you're uh you're making a
big difference it's doing all right
isn't it yeah it's doing all right
definitely one of the fastest growing
platforms I might have to jump on yeah
especially with Mario shoes I tell you I
always pissing people off
um look I just want to say thank you
you're an absolutely amazing person
thanks I know that um your heart is
always in the right place and I can
honestly say of all of the people I've
interviewed I've never met anyone who's
more kind more loving than caring than
you are that's lovely that's the best
that's what we want to be designed nice
people that's it sometimes I want to be
such extravagant things but what else is
really then kindness one last question
yeah we'll wrap it on this how would you
like to be remembered
I try not to think about things like
that because otherwise my vanity and
grandiosity will take place and I'll
start thinking about like you know all
of the sort of the cellophane ocean that
surrounded Kensington Palace when Diana
died it's probably just best that I let
go of we'll have Elton singing you off
the Pearly Goods that's all I require
just now on John changing the words of
Norma Jean or Rocket Man any of them
really they're all classics have you
Mountain
yeah I have met him and he was all right
I met him like I think I met him at
dinner somewhere and I've like I wrote
too much about stuff to do with recovery
and he was pretty nice yeah he's good
with that he's saved Robbie Williams
when he was in his back I think yeah he
turned up at Robbie's house and went
come on we're putting in rehab off you
go come that's enough now Rob uh we'll
leave it there that was Russell Brand on
the true Geordie podcast one of the
goats thank you very much we'll catch
you on the next one cheers thank you
[Music]
oh